[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport c'est le septième numéro
deux cette saison sur tv 78 et le 116e
de l'histoire de la chaîne vous l'aurez
compris vous êtes ici dans une
institution au programme comme toujours
une dose de bonne humeur des analyses
sportives et surtout des coups de gueule
et des débats nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite vous le
connaissez tous il vient de voir des
contrées versaillaise il adore le golf
et le rugby mais il peut s'exprimer
surtout on le surnomme dans cette
émission le à gladiator mais aujourd'hui
pas d'armure mais un volume costume de
noël pierre chevallier est avec nous
pendant une heure
les gouvernements elle est là ça va très
bien les couleurs de circonstance pour
cette émission spéciale noël dans
l'esprit magique de noël vous êtes en
pleine forme en plein salon du sport des
paillettes on y va on continue notre
tour de table musique lui a l'habitude
des plateaux de télévision c'est une
légende de ce talk il connaît tout sur
tout mais il est trop humble pour
l'admettre on le surnomme dans cette
émission l'italian lover gregory k la
légion et tchité v60 site est avec nous
bonjour michael bonjour pierre bonjour à
tous quand allez-vous super bonnets de
noël mais voilà j'avais pas le pull
moche de noël j'ai pas forcément
respecter le thème on a on a un pull
dans dans l'esprit de noël et donc j'ai
rajouté le bonnet du père noël pour être
totalement dans le thème la moquette en
dessous la moc états de l'italian
forcément voilà c'est votre cagnotte du
ski c'est ça c'est ça c'est pour se
réchauffer au coin du feu avec un petit
chocolat chaud l'hiver et on est bien
avec mariah carey enfants alors on
continue à ma droite musique lui aussi
est une légende de cette émission c'est
un spécialiste basket mais il s'y
connaît dans tous les sports il joue
dans le club de basket de trappes et il
a une grande expérience internationale
it's showtime
nice menton go vitalic à limoges en tous
comment allez vous ça va très bien comme
il l'a dit l'argent dans un esprit de
noël et puis et puis en espérant que je
vais apporter pas mal de cadeaux tout le
monde alors on s'y perdrait là aussi
pour vous sur votre pull un oui bien sûr
de soi là dans l'esprit mots derrière
dans l'esprit du temps effectivement
alors un terminal à gauche musique s'est
lui aussi une encyclopédie vivante sur
le monde du sport et notamment sur le
football et le golf il a l'expérience
des grands rendez vous c'est pour cela
qu'on l'a intégré à cette émission la
légende vivante patrice carmouze sera
avec nous pendant une heure
pour talent et vous bataillez ça va ça
va je vais faire la guerre avec les
stars
pour faire débat sur le sur le baudet de
grégory talking to pas à je sais pas
peut-être
ça fait déjà un gros débat avant
l'émission et le rationnement retrait
comme
c'est un bonnet perdu un peu peut-être
mettre une alerte enlèvement je ne sais
pas
c'était quelqu'un qui avait des poux qui
avait
viré bien prennent alors avant de passer
au programme de l'émission va parler de
basket la ligue nationale de basket
vient de dévoiler la liste des 20
joueurs sélectionnés pour le all star
game français le 29 décembre prochain on
retrouvera sur le parquet de l'accord
hôtel arena 1 yvelinois le prodige
victor webb anyama été retenu pour
participer à l'événement il sera
remplaçant dans l'équipe de france face
à l'équipe des étrangers le joueur de
l'asvel passait par le
chesnay-versailles état à 17 ans l'une
des plus grandes promesses du basket
français à l excès écoutez moi bien deux
mètres 19 il attire tous les regards des
scouts de la nba alors la question sur
ce thème est ce que ce n'est pas trop
tôt pour le sélectionné pour le all star
game voter oui ou non ce que vous en
pensez
oui pour vous patrice oui pour vous
grégory non pour vous pierre allait
enfin un petit ventre trop tôt n'est ce
pas trop tôt c'est pas trop tôt c'est
bien j'ai bien c'est bien alors enfin
salué jean grey lille grégory et tiens
tiens vous commencé et je commence donc
ce n'est pas trop tôt pour pas trop tôt
non parce que c'est le all star game
sait pas encore c'est pas encore des
grosses compétitions où ça peut être
vraiment haché et des matches des
matches difficiles c'est de l'exhibition
dont celle événementiel un prodige comme
celui là vous l'avez vous a rappelé ses
mensurations même si il est beaucoup
plus long que large et qui va il va
encore sans plus mais
de l'avenir c'est une petite pépite
qu'il faut voir des comptes dès qu'on
peut en gros en plus de son de son club
de l'asvel est sûre sur un match
exhibition comme le all star game où on
réunit tous les meilleurs joueurs
français du championnat et les étrangers
du championnat il faut il faut le voir
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de risque il
n'y a pas trop y a pas de risque il sera
passible et il sera pas il sera pas mis
en danger sur un match exhibition donc
non pas trop tôt parce qu'il faut qu'on
il faut qu'ils se frottent aussi à des
événements des événements et du public
télévisé il ya déjà le ya déjà là
programme comme ça mais en gros c'est le
bon moment pour le pour le montrer
qu'ils sortent un petit peu du bois et
puis continuer à le montrer il va y va
il va aller très haut il est déjà très
haut il va aller très haut ce petit ce
petit victor grégory qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça mais on le rappelle il est
remplaçant moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus une sélection un peu de buzz
qu'une sélection sur le plan sportif je
m'explique depuis le début de saison où
victor webb anyama a joué très peu de
matches aller avec l'asvel alors il n'a
pas été épargné il est il a une longue
fièvre un moment donné à un virus qui
l'a qui l'éloigné des terrains et qui
l'a cloué au lit pendant pendant
quelques semaines
c'était vols quotidiens il s'est aussi
fracturé le droit un le doit à un moment
donné sûrement la main droite c'est
d'ailleurs et celle là ça lui là aussi
éloigné des terrains pendant trois
semaines donc j'ai l'impression plus sur
ses performances sportives auront la
part on n'a pas regardé sur ses
performances sportives plus sur le buzz
et forcément ou mba nyama dès qu'ils
sortent quelque part il ya sa photo il
est plus haut que tout le monde il est
plus grand que tout le monde de mettre
19 on sait que il est suivi par les les
spécialistes de la nba qui le voient
déjà premier à la draft en 2023 j'ai
peur qu'on le met peut-être trop trop
tôt laissons le montrer c'est ses
preuves et faire ses preuves avec
l'asvel et je ne crains que sa fin je
crains que ça ça va ça va le projeter
trop vite sur lt servir pour vous on
voit ça peut le desservir cette
sélection all-star game alors qu'il n'a
pas forcément montré tout son potentiel
encore sur les terrains matrix qui vous
a convaincu pierre ou grégory
c'est le m ap du basket quoi donc on a
envie de le d'abord envie de le voir en
tant que spectateur c'est vrai qu'on a
envie de voir il a raison de dire c'est
pas les jeux olympiques c'est pas une
compétition voilà c'est plutôt une
exhibition donc c'est bien de le voir et
puis c'est bien de le voir au haut
niveau avec avec d'autres avec les
joueurs de l'équipe de france avec avec
des très grands joueurs donc c'est bien
de le voir aussi à ce niveau là c'est
vrai que son problème c'est des
blessures un peuvent qu il a accumulé
les jeunes lorsqu'ils ces jeunes
beaucoup de blessures j'ai grandi très
vite mais je crois qu'on a envie de voir
qu'il a envie aussi de se voir avec les
autres
mike qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors
vous vous connaissez très bien à victor
wanyama vous commentez notamment les
matchs de la nba mais vous suit avec
attention le championnat de france je
suis et ce que vous en pensez de victor
webb maniema basque d'avant je suis
jetée mitigé moix pour ça que ce qu'il a
dit jean ou y je partage parce que enfin
pierre plus tôt excusez moi et c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu mitigé mais
après pour ma part pour parler pts que
les outils dont 10 sur le plateau ce qui
est important c'est qu'il a été dur a
été sélectionné par rapport à ça son
potentiel c'est à dire qu'elles sont
caractéristiques à devenir un très bon
joueur faut pas oublier que c'est un
joueur qui va se faire racheter d'ici
les prochaines années et voir les loups
draft en 2023 normalement exactement
donc donc voilà il va être sur moi est
le français le plus drafté plus haut
niveau du classement en sachant qu'on a
on sait qu'on a des gars comme qui
l'année ce qui étaient draft en septième
position ou des tony parker et j'en
passe mais
pas forcément il ya des gens qui
regardent
ces appelés par ce sont les plus grands
potentiels
de la terre entière on peut dire
exactement c'est exactement ça tous les
meilleurs joueurs européens ou de
l'adhérence valley aux états unis et qui
vont être soit grave tant premier
tournoi d'hier sur les 30 premiers et un
deuxième tour où ils prennent d'être ans
les 30 les 30 restant jusqu'aux cinq ans
donc c'est un peu ça et puis aussi comme
il a dit greg c'est un peu aussi le buzz
c'est le prodige français où tout le
monde a envie de le voir c'est un
formulaire qui et qui sait un formule 1
qui est plutôt exceptionnel parce que
oui parce que quand on regarde
finalement ces procès cinq dernières
rencontres ses cinq derniers matchs ils
marquent en moyenne cinq à six points
donc c'est pas forcément fabuleux en 16
minutes de jeu il a pris beaucoup de
rebonds par contre notamment face à
orléans avec 8 rebonds il réalise
environ une passes décisives par match
on voit que c'est un jeu un joueur en
devenir
regarde ses statistiques pour l'instant
il n'a pas encore trouvé son rythme de
croisière parce qu'il était blessé comme
on l'a dit
plus exactement elle était blessé donc
voilà il faut lui laisser un peu le
temps mais c'est un formulaire qui qui
va être bien pour lui je pense je pense
en plus je sais de quoi je parle en
termes de plutôt de l'excès inverse en
petite taille je pense qu'il doit avoir
aussi en ce moment il est encore en
croissance un besoin et un impératif de
prendre possession de son corps l'aca
doit ça doit pas forcément être évident
sur un sur un parquet de basket de de
mouvoir les deux mètres 19 l'envers dur
qu'il a on a revu une photo avec le
hamburger qu'il a avec ses deux bras il
faut qu'ils puissent l'utiliser savoir
l'utiliser son corps comme une
communarde vous parliez des rebonds
c'est quand on fait une tête une
technique plus que quasiment tout seul
tout le tout les joueurs de dd deux cinq
majeurs qui sont déjà grands et plus tôt
on a des facilités mais je pense que à
son âge et en développement physique il
faut il faut qu'ils prennent possession
de son corps qui se muscle aussi parce
qu'il est plutôt il est plutôt élancée
que costaud de manière à pouvoir
justement encaissés et les matches de
pro de pro a et d'euroligue et puis et
puis bientôt bientôt la nba il fait 3 cm
de plus sain que rudy gobert qui était
l'un des plus grands français assure sur
les parquets odigo vers 2016 2019 pour
victor maniema qui n'a toujours pas
terminé de sa croissance un grégory qui
n'a pas terminé sa croissance nous ça va
se terminer sur ses listes à bientôt se
terminer oui mais il doit encore
progresser
pierre le rappeler le rappeler très bien
il doit encore progresser notamment sur
le travail défensif qui est peut-être
encore son d'hirson son point faible on
sent que dans le physique il faut qu'ils
prennent aussi un peu plus d'ampleur on
va voir là il avait perdu je disais 7
kilos quand il a eu son son virus donc
forcément une un retour sur les parquets
qui va être long on va on commence à le
revoir il a joué neuf minutes
intéressantes 1 contre monaco lors du
dernier match cette semaine donc on va
le revoir maintenant moi j'ai peur que
sur la sélection buzz ce ne soit trop
tôt peut-être alex il a 30 ans il
ya aucun risque par rapport à ça le
céleri c'est peut-être se dire que qui
prennent le volant mais je pense pas du
tout parce que c'est un garçon qui est
assez stable quand même et donc par
rapport à ça non et si en plus c'est un
contexte un peu nba pascal all star
games et ses besoins de chaud je sais
y'a plein d'événements sur le sujet nous
devrons d'humains donc donc voila mais
après dans l'ensemble c'est un gamin qui
doit progresser dans pas mal de choses
voilà il ya encore tout jeune donc il ya
plein de choses à travailler ce sera
peut-être la seule occasion pour le
public français de voir victor urbaniana
dans un match comme celui là
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de tennis et des premiers
matchs d'une autre yvelinois arthur
rinderknecht en coupe davis coup de
projecteur également sur le 7e ballon
d'or du joueur du psg lionel messi
mérite est il ce ballon d'or 2021 nous
nous poserons la question mais avant de
parler de ces thèmes on va parler
football et de la coupe de france
[Musique]
on va donc parler football et de la
coupe de france au 8e tour toutes les
yvelines on scrute avec attention ce
derby est rarissime à ce niveau de la
compétition
versailles recevait poissy à fin
novembre un match équilibré qui si
finalement soldée par une qualification
dé versailles et sur le score de 1 but à
0 avec une réalisation de christopher
iba yi un match longtemps indécis qui
aurait pu voir poissy l'emporter
plusieurs décisions arbitrales en était
litigieuse en fin de match voici aurait
peut-être pu bénéficier d'un penalty il
ya eu un but refusé pour un hors-jeu
quoi qu'il en soit versailles sera en
32e de finale en plus d'être deuxièmes
du championnat de nationale 2 un début
de saison idéal pour versailles la
question sur ce thème doit-on tomber
dans l'euphorie après cette
qualification en 32e de finale de la
coupe de france où voter oui ou non est
ce qu'on doit tomber dans l'euphorie oui
pour vous patrice non à ma patrie ce
sera votre premier temps pour cette
émission alors patrice vous commencez on
va le pierre pour répondre à patrice
donc j'ai bien si vous tombez dans le
forez moyen d'aborder content c'est
formidable pour ce club qui a de
l'ambition qu'il commence à s'armer et
l'arrivée de jean luc arribart il ya un
bon valais il ya des gens qui il ya des
structures qui sont en train de se
renforcer aussi la raison qui devient le
nouveau directeur général de l'équipe
seniors les équipes seniors qui va qui
va donc il vient pas pour rien je
suppose donc c'est un club qui a de
l'ambition qui deuxième vous le disais
de dons qui peut monter en national j'ai
passé de l'euphorie mais c'est vachement
bien si j'ai alors là je pense qu'en
plus ils vont ils vont être et on sait
pas contre qui sont contre un club plus
faible de sarre union lloris après lyon
alors sa réunion un club alsacien qui
évolue alors en nationale 3 donc voilà
c'est forcément une belle occasion en
national n'a pas toujours de jeu chic en
faute et ils ont des chances d'arriver
en 16e c'est quand même formidable se
pose et qui rencontre le psg en 16e
c'est leur rêve je crois ça serait celle
de l'euphorie pour les gens de
versailles pour aller voir pour les
supporteurs pour les pour les joueurs
aussi c'est quand même c'est comme une
magnifique aventure la coupe de france à
la coupe de la ligue on sait ça a été
condamné parce que ça ne reposait pas
sur grand chose la coupe de france c'est
l'histoire même du foot donc bah oui dès
que dès qu'un club de nationale 2 arrive
en 32e on peut être foriic tiers mais
c'est vrai qu'on
attention vous connaissez très bien
aller vers
versailles
ne pas bouder son plaisir de la verser
dans l'euphorie vraiment répondre à
votre question non pour 2,2 question de
contexte la première et patrice l'a
rappelé est sûre c'est sur le en fait
l'évolution l'évolution prochaine dans
un futur très proche du club de
versailles qui se structure qui est
passée qui a passé un cap en terme de
budget qui théoriquement devrait le
faire en terme d'organisation de
structuration avec quelques grands noms
qui qui arrive qui végète ça va ça va ça
va le faire sur l'été prochain et sur le
prochain mercato
surtout si la montée
est le deuxième le deuxième point c'est
sur les peut-être cinq dernières saisons
de versailles qui ont été quand même
relativement sérieuse sportivement dire
qu'il ya eu des tours de tours de fronde
de coupe de france il ya eu il ya eu des
belles perf et la soeur de championnat
8e tour de coupe de france en décembre
2018 contre lens il est en deuxième de
finale de la coupe de france face à
granville en 2020 beaucoup d'eau qui se
bat on va dire il s'était presque
habitué avait adea des belles
performances en coupe de france on en
parle suffisamment ici en disant cette
compétition est magique et ça pour le
coup c'est un des gros avantages du
football d'avoir cette cette compétition
il y avait le challenge yves du manoir
au rugby mais rien à voir avec cette
possibilité qu'ont les clubs amateurs de
rencontrer des pros ou un petit peu plus
loin dans la compétition et versailles
est habitué à ces à ses performances il
ya eu ce match contre lens que vous
rappeliez qui font tellement habitués
qu'on doit pas
je dis qu'on ne boude pas notre plaisir
mais faut pas s'emballer souvenez-vous
pas s'emballer là le tour en plus leur
est favorable le tour le taux le 32e qui
joue le 18 l'aurait plutôt favorable sur
le papier ne nous emballons pas mais on
peut là vraiment voir le 16e et l'a
peut-être 16e etienne là on pourra tous
s'en aller et verser dans l'euphorie et
sa dépendance du parc de grégory canales
hurle sur l'issue du match
mike et qu'est ce que vous en pensez à
l'heure où vous étiez partagé qui vous a
convaincu
non j'étais pas partagé mais c'est comme
je les dis c'est bien pour le pour le
sport ici dans la région c'est bien pour
le football après après faut pas faut
pas s'emballer parce que comme il l'a
dit
l'objectif du club c'est s'inscrire dans
la durée donc on sait qu'à la fin le
terrain il va parler parce que si jamais
vous juste que je sais pas moi s'ils
vont passer ce tour-là à la fin de la
journée c'est il faut gagner la
compétition si on la gagne pas c'est pas
c'est pas si savard quand même peut-être
l'histoire du club parce que le meilleur
parcours de versets en sus de france et
un seizième de finale grégory à vous
confirmer 1948 une défaite face à
gueugnon à l'époque les débats mais les
époques l'entente sportive versaillaise
oui alors moi je suis d'accord avec
78 c'est ça sur ce que disait pierre si
effectivement versa et se qualifie en
16e de finale là on pourra tomber dans
l'euphorie pourquoi il faut pas tomber
tout de suite dans l'euphorie parce
qu'il n'ya pas un adversaire non plus de
renom en face de versailles pour ce 32e
de finale c'est une équipe qui est moins
bien loties elles en nationale 3 donc
une division en dessous dé versailles et
donc si les versaillais se font sortir
dès les 32e de finale c'est un peu la
douche froide on aurait pu être fort
hills il y avait eu dès les 32e un match
face au paris saint-germain là il y
avait de quoi être euphorique moi je
pense qu'il faut après un tirage au sort
qui qui nous fait justement parce qu'on
n'est pas encore dans l'euphorie et qui
dit thérèse vasseur disque peut
peut-être 16e peut-être 8e et quart de
finale non ça ne s'est pas donc pourquoi
bouder au plaisir après ce
faux que c'est versailles soit sérieux
élimine cette équipe normalement on s'y
fait respecter sa hiérarchie après on
verra peut-être un tour face au paris
saint-germain juste pour à titre de
comparaison mais j'avais assisté à un
match d'un club amateur face au paris
saint-germain un club en est seul linas
montlhéry face à quasiment vingt mille
supporters c'est un 32e de finale là il
y avait de l'euphorie c'était une fête
totale et je pense que les joueurs de
linas montlhéry s'en souviendront encore
pendant pendant longtemps attendons de
voir une affiche une telle affiche pour
versailles et il faut d'abord qu'ils
passent contre sarre union et ce sera
pas une mince affaire après je
logiquement plus y gagneront deux tours
pluie devrait rencontrer de demain au
club normal
dans la coupe de france c'est des
parcours comme calais comme clermont
foot à l'époque et c'est quand on se
comprend le scalp de deux clubs de ligue
2 de ligue 1 l'as l'euphorie elle est là
parce que il ya un tel décalage au
départ sur la fiche que là quand les
amateurs passe au mental à
à l' enthousiasme et à l'euphorie
lallaoui là on peut se lâcher
c'est sur versailles c'est un club qui
monte qui est encore en nationale 3
enfin c'était la dh encore il ya
quelques quelques années qui qui monte
en championnat qui est deuxième en
nationale 2 derrière lorient et en plus
derrière une réserve qu il le racontera
pas et qui ne peut pas monter donc oui
il ya de quoi être enthousiaste
l'euphorie que je ne sais pas encore
cela dit si c'est vrai que s'ils passent
pas le 3e place après le forez ce sera
le faux plat
c'est vraiment la structuration du club
c'est ça qui est beau il ya
quelque chose de bien on a parlé c'est
un promoteur immobilier a vraiment qui a
injecté de l'argent dans le club c'est
fi du sim city qu'injecter entre 4 et 5
millions d'euros on connaît pas
exactement les chiffes mais ça se
chiffre à plusieurs millions d'euros on
parle même peut-être d'un futur stade
sur le plateau de satory on ne sait pas
encore c'est ça finalement
en
nocturne au stade maubon
125 km on ne peut pas grand de lumière
la nuit six châteaux ses seins donc
c'est un club qui se structure makamba
jenson était bien un exemple aussi pour
tout le monde parce que pour construire
un club c'est il il faut pas que de
l'argent il faut l'argent il faut des
personnes pauvres il faut les joueurs
pour donc ça commence toujours de par la
hausse jusque jusqu'au joueur donc donc
c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
démontrer donc après il faut voir sur la
continuité ce que ça va donner on suivra
ça en tout cas avec attention la
rencontre de coupe de france ce sera le
18 décembre prochain en alsace bon
courage au versailles et on passe à
notre prochain sujet en tennis li vinoir
tueur et 9,9 à jouer fin novembre en
coupe davis avec l'équipe de france ce
bilan mitigé le joueur de 26 ans a perdu
ensemble face à cameron nouri 12e
mondial 6-2 7-6 mais il a remporté le
double avec nicolas mahut 6 1 6 4 face à
la grande bretagne mais les bleus sont
éliminés de la compétition il a annoncé
après son tournoi vouloir garder le
positif et surtout sa première victoire
dans la compétition arthur riner tenait
à cheveux saint germanois qui est le
beau fils de patrick ottawa le
conseiller sportif territorial du comité
des yvelines de tennis patrick ottawa
nous donne son avis sur ses performances
à la coupe davis on l'écouté g d'abord
regardé son match de simple et son match
de double c'est une vraie fierté pour
nous parce qu'en fait il a eu un
comportement exemplaire il a deux balles
de set au second j'aurais bien aimé voir
un troisième saut aurait pu basculer
il a été très combatif très vaillants
très concentré très performant en double
et on va dire que c'est c'était une
journée de premiere première sélection
en équipe de france première fois numéro
un de l'équipe le première défaite
première défaite en coupe davis première
victoire mais un bilan super positif et
je pense que ça va l'aider encore à
passer un cap la question sur cette
thématique est ce qu'on peut dire que
les débuts d'arthur are in darkness avec
l'équipe de france sont réussis oui ou
non voter
oui bon c'est toujours unanimes pas
débat merci au revoir alors grégory
qu'il suit avec attention car c'est long
non mais c'est déjà c'était une surprise
dans cette équipe de france il faut le
rappeler il passe devant gaël monfils
qui a n'a pas été appelé c'était le
grand absent on va dire à de ce
rassemblement de l'équipe de france de
coupe davis sur le bilan comptable il
fait une défaite une victoire sur sur le
double sur le 5 faut pas oublier qu'il
voit quand même contre le 12e mondial
lui est encore à une 58e place même s'il
a fait une progression fulgurante sur
cette année 2021 façon la 170e à la 58e
place il encore un cap à franchir ces
délits qu'il était à deux doigts de le
battre enfin pas le passé en tout cas
égaliser dans le deuxième set la petite
déception s'il faut titiller quelque
part c'est qu'il avait eu deux balles de
set dans le deuxième set justement qu'il
y aurait pu lui permettre voilà deux de
jouer on va dire ses chances jusqu'au
bout face à à cameron on ne rit
maintenant il remporte quand même son
match de double avec
avec mahut donc c'est quand même une
expérience acquise pour lui qui lui sera
je pense
qu'il lui sera profitable sur l'année
2022 attendons de voir comment il va
pouvoir profiter de cette expérience
mais la progression elle est tellement
fulgurante et c'est la petite cerise sur
le gâteau cette convocation en équipe de
france de coupe davis qu'on ne peut pas
être déçu de cette prestation patrice on
l'attendait pas vraiment rénove
finalement c'est une victoire et une
défaite à deux doigts d'une d'une
victoire en tout cas d'un match très
serré
c'est pas facile dans une première
sélection de coupe davis de se comporter
comme çà sert aucune pression il ya même
si la coupe davis n'est plus la même que
celle qu'elle était autrefois et puis on
sent bien qu'il ya un changement de
génération qui est en train de venir là
dans le tennis français allaient les les
mots fils lèvera d'être tous ceux qui
tout ce que même mon fils est souvent
blessé mais faut il ya un appel à une
nouvelle génération y les paillettes
gaston qui n'était pas là non plus
qu'ils auraient pu l'être il fait partie
de ceux là il est pas tout jeune cela
dit lundi la voile à 26 ans il est pro
seulement depuis deux à huit faire c est
un type car il sait en plus et ça ça
n'est pas qui vous êtes et hérité au
texas qui fait des études qui avaient de
finances et ses quelques une forte
maturité donc c'est bien ça représente
peut-être l'avenir du tennis français
c'est pour ça que c'est pas c'est pas
décevant après on gagne on perd ça
arrive c'est sûr c'est pas le crack
qu'on a découvert qu
il a passé des étapes
sécurité qui est nécessaire sans fin sur
l'histoire
il est arrivé sur le tard sur le tard
sur le ou tennis et c'est un peu comme
ça c'est ce que m'a dit le comité des
yvelines de tennis ils étaient quatre à
partir aux etats-unis et c'est le seul
finalement qui arriva à percer alors
c'était peut-être le moins bon à la base
oui car il ya un gros gros potentiel et
après sur la
pense à la question il ya son mots sont
simples il le perd sur un score fort
honorable contre le 12e qu'on a un 12e
mondial donc c'est quand même cette
fameuse défaite encourageante et puis et
puis en double il faut pas oublier quand
même qui remplace entre guillemets
herbert qu'avec survenu sur une sur une
paire mike vermeer qui est une des
meilleures au monde et il arrive à se
hisser au niveau et a gagné a gagné son
match donc c'est à son âge us ont vu son
parcours et puis en gros le potentiel
qui malgré tous ces c s'est fait jour
assez rapidement c'est très encourageant
pour le pour l'avenir dont cette gêne et
dense est effectivement c'est de se
risquer sur ces
gros changement
parce que bon on aurait pu mais il a mis
sur la touche mon fils pour prendre un
gros déclic été plus son rythme il fait
que
deux matches cette saison sur ce match a
aussi fait un mètre 80 mètre 87 ans il
est dans les standards existants
d'ariane et de donc les tous meilleurs
oui donc gros service
mike qu'est ce que vous en pensez ou non
ce qui est important c'est c'est un peu
son positionnement vis-à-vis de tout ça
c'est un garçon qui se prend pas trop la
tête et il prend les choses comme et
arrive et ça se voit à travers son
cursus au départ il n'était pas parti
pour le tennis il fait ses études et ils
sont en train d'un côté et finalement il
se voit qu'il est capable de faire pas
mal de choses non pour lui je pense que
tout est bénéfique qui seront pas trop
la tête et en plus ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est qu'il maîtrise
les codes médiatiques c'est à dire que
il sait de quoi parler et de quoi ne pas
parler souvent ils parlent souvent de
ses objectifs où il les dit pas au grand
public mais tu sens qu'il ya un travail
de fond qui est fait avec son entraîneur
il sait où il veut aller mais en même
temps il est il assez réservé par
rapport à ça et je pense que on a on a
un prodige et même s'il veut pas
l'avouer devant tout le monde mais mais
voilà il faut compter avec lui mais
serait forcée jeu l'avancé déjà des
infos elle rejoint patrice et mike là
dessus c'est que il un parcours
complètement atypique par rapport aux
autres aux autres tennisman qui sont
situés la sic les mains ficelé gasquet
qu'on a tout de suite projeté très
jeunes sur sur le devant de la scène
mondiale lui est arrivé tard donc
peut-être qu'il aura pas la même
pression que ses autres joueurs et ça
peut l'aider je pense même sur une
progression qui peut continuer sur
l'année 2022 c'est un très gros travail
en d'après ses coachs il s'entraîne et
il veut gagner des matches et à côté de
ça il s'en fiche en gros ils s'en
fichent de la médiatisation lui ce qu'il
veut c'est gagner des matches patrice
c'est positif et en plus c'est une
faille le dit d'ailleurs je crois même
si on m'en vais lancer plus tôt j'aurais
été nulle quoi enfin je ne ferai rien
fait sur le circuit c'est qu'il a
attendu cette maturité pour se lancer
pour choisir ce qu'ils avaient envie de
faire pour être sûr d'avoir d'avoir
envie de devenir pro et et de jouer le
circuit quoi ce qui paraît ce qui est
pas un truc évident c'est pour ça que
pour ça que ni la défaite 10 la victoire
des enfants y aura pas il n'a pas eu
d'euphorie après la victoire en double
est de même de près par les pressions
après la défaite en sable c'est un type
bien structuré quoi promis le contexte
aussi de la coupe davis qui ressemble
plus vraiment à la coupe davis quand on
a tout ce qu'on a tous peur est-ce que
ça est ce que ça joue sur le mental ou
sur les performances de nos joueurs
peut-être pour les plus jeunes peut-être
s'il ya un gros jeu proposant la
tradition on se pose pas de question ne
se pose pas de questions il ya moins de
physique
personne n'y avait personne on l'a donc
il est je pense un peu plus serein que
que quelqu'un qui aurait déclaré démarré
dans les années 90 il n'était pas
attendu ils étaient pas il n'était pas
vraiment attendu donc il fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin c'est ça qui est
intéressant la boîte à dons sont pas
tellement plus cela sur cette équipe de
france sûre mahut à herbert du coup
cette paire qui gagne tout plutôt que
sur arthur neiges qui n'avait jamais
joué peut-être c'est ce que voulait dire
oui exactement c'est exactement ça à
noter également qu arthur et maintenat
chez le 2e et binoy à percer au plus
haut niveau après à mika llodra donc ces
numéros de leurs valises et dans le
relais dans les deux relais dans les
quatre mousquetaires il n'y a pas dit le
droit
je ne crois pas alors tout cas on
souhaite bon courage à un tir énarque
neige pour sa saison 2022 une saison
qu'on suivra avec attention
[Musique]
on va maintenant passer à l'envolée de
grégory le moment le plus incroyable
plus cérébral de cette émission ne pas
les veut nous parler du trophée douze
rondes ouvrons dont vous rêviez voilà
elle commence très bien cette chronique
petit centrale lorsque vous couriez
derrière un ballon je sais que vous avez
rêvé de ce trophée vous leur emporteriez
à coup sûr si en plus des footballeurs
il était ouvert aux journalistes de
sport on nous parle que de lui noël
approchant c'est bien sûr le ballon d'or
alors le 29 novembre dernier lionel
messi a remporté le ballon d'or france
football 2000 21 le 7e pour la pulga
dans sa carrière lui qui est le
recordman à deux unités désormais devant
son rival cristiano ronaldo et ses cinq
titres et pour nos chroniqueurs du sop
sport il y a de quoi être heureux un
club français que dis-je des yvelines
basée dans les yvelines dans le
département le paris saint germain qui
obtient son premier ballon d'or dans
l'histoire il est vrai que l'argentin
est né dans la capitale que depuis
quelques mois et que l'essentiel de ces
performances ont été réalisées à
barcelone mais le psg avait subi la même
injustice en 1995 avec jean rejouer un
qui a venait de quitter les parisiens et
qui avait remporté la distinction
individuelle sous les couleurs du bayern
munich injustice c'est le mot qui me
vient à l'esprit en parlant de ce ballon
d'or 2021 est loin de moi l'idée de
remettre en cause le talent et le génie
de lionel messi nous ne reverrons pas de
sitôt un tel joueur qui en plus de nous
avoir régalés nous a offert sans doute
la plus grande rivalité est de tous les
temps avec le portugais ses recettes
mais cette année non les eaux ne
méritait pas cette distinction ou en
tout cas d'autres la méritait plus que
lui je vous arrête tout de suite je ne
parlerai pas de karim benzema je vais
m'en tenir uniquement au podium de ce
ballon d'or 2000 21 qui va sans doute s
afficher mon favori de cette année est
arrivé en deuxième position son nom
robert lewandowski bien sûr il a marché
sur l'eau la saison dernière avec le
bayern munich au moment de la clôture
des votes du ballon d'or fin octobre ce
sont les statistiques qui apparaissent
et qui comptabilise les chiffres en club
et aussi en sélection 54 buts pour le
polonais 7 passes décisives mieux vous
le voyez que lionel messi avec ses 40
buts et 14 passes décisives alors sur le
plan individuel robert lewandowski des
ventes devançant lionel messi le
polonais et le soulier d'or européen
c'est à dire le meilleur buteur du
continent sur la saison dernière avec 41
buts dans le championnat allemand il a
fait aussi tomber le record historique
de gerd muller 1 sur une saison qui
courait depuis la saison 1971 1972 bref
légendaire robert lewandowski on ne sait
plus trop vers quoi aller avec ce ballon
d'or je vais m'expliquer des fois on
avance que c'est le meilleur joueur
individuel sur une saison donc on va
mettre en avant les performances
individuelles sur une saison pour et
bien désigner le ballon d'or là-bas le
compte n'y est pas puisque robert
lewandowski je vous le disais à une
meilleure statistique à lionel messi
l'autre motivation l'autre raison pour
le ballon d'or qui est souvent aussi
affiché c'est le jour le plus
déterminant au sein de son équipe celui
qui a fait à gagner aussi à son équipe
des trophées déterminant là les pros
mais s'ils vont dire que et bien il ya
la copa america le premier titre obtenu
avec l'argentine qui a plus de valeur
qu'une bundesliga où la coupe du monde
des clubs gagné par les munich par le
munichois mais même sur ce point
regarder de palmarès sur la saison
dernière messi est battu george iny au
troisième sur le podium du ballon d'or a
gagné lui la ligue des champions avec
chelsea et l'euro avec l'équipe d'italie
j'ai été obligé de parler dit allié dans
cette chronique 19h forcément mais soit
donc c'était les deux trophées majeurs
forcément qui a qui s'offrait à lui sur
sur cette saison alors même si c'est
pour ça que ça vous a énervé un non
c'est pas pour ça que jamais y arriver
non oui j'ai dit que c'était robert
lewandowski mais à l'italo brésilien je
pense n'a pas remporté le ballon d'or
parce que il n'a pas été aussi
déterminant on ne retient pas georges
ignaux forcément dans le titre de
chelsea dans le titre de l'italie donc
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'on ne l'a
pas choisie mais voilà le doute m'empare
et j'aurais voulu quand même voir robert
lewandowski cette année il va rejoindre
malheureusement le club de ces oubliés
du ballon d'or dans les dernières années
on ne peut penser forcément à ribéry à
schnyder à iniesta à bouffonne à neuer à
maldini ou encore beckham tant de noms
qui sont passés tout près mais qui n'ont
pas gagné cette distinction alors
l'injustice et là on ne peut pas revenir
en arrière désormais mais je pense qu'on
peut réparer cette injustice en donnant
le ballon d'or 2020 à robert lewandowski
le ballon d'or 2000 vent le rappel qui
avait été supprimée temps de pandémie
qu'ovide oblige je pense que pour
racheter cette injustice pour à la
rattraper en tout cas on devra lui
donner ce ballon d'or 2020 qu'est ce que
vous en pensez est-ce qu'il faut donner
un parent d'or en 2009
hold up très haut niveau ah oui pourquoi
parce que je pense que le juge de paix
c'est quoi c'est en juin joueurs sur
l'ensemble de la saison c'est pas que
sur la copa america que sur l'ensemble
de la saison et puis après il ya les
statistiques individuelles collectif et
quand on regarde sur les deux saisons
qu'on vient de dire greg levono ce qui
mérite d'être des deux ballons d'or
après ce n'est pas scandaleux que messi
lui mais ici c'est quand même un garçon
qui est prodigieux depuis ce qu'il fait
ce qu'il fallait depuis depuis des
années maintenant avec avec l'argentine
et barcelone mais moi je trouve que
cette année voilà il sait pas c'est pas
du tout méritée c'est pas du tout
méritée a encore une fois
je le disais tantôt quand et polonais
c'est pas pareil que quand un argentin
quand tu es un brésilien c'est pas
pareil que quand un polonais il ya aussi
l'aspect l'aura médiatique parce qu'il
faut se dire la vérité les ceux qui
votent c'est vraiment les journalistes
et donc tous à sa survie
les journalistes sélectionneurs un
moment il y avait un accord entre france
football et la fifa où il y avait un mix
entre journalistes et sélectionneurs et
capitaines aussi des sélections je crois
que c'était 200 sélections et deux cents
200 capitaine 200 sélectionneur plus et
j'en ai demandé depuis 2016 on est
revenu à l'ancienne formule du ballon
dans la formule historique avec
seulement des journalistes et ya deux
cents près de 200 journalistes dans le
monde qui votent pour ce bas monde
entier
après juste pour finir ce qui est quand
même marrant en fait dans cette histoire
c'est messi quand il fait son discours
il parle de lewandowski donc et pas
lui-même il sait qu'il n'est pas c'est
pas légitime son mandant d'or mais
est-ce qu'il peut le refuser
moi je dirais justement et j'aime su
poser ces questions là je me suis dit un
gars comme messi ou les regarder dans le
monde entier il a inspiré énormément
d'enfants le fait de reconnaître que
franchement je mérite pas le ballon d'or
je te le donne pour moi c'est une classe
incroyable et ça changerait énormément
l'image de cette société qui est
concentré que sur soi même et je pense
que oui pour vous pouvez le faire d'un
organe et 6 déjà deux ballons d'or enfin
franchement loupé les classes chez lui
je
sais enfin il y avait assez marrant tous
ces enfants ne sais même plus combien il
en avait gagné ouest lycée mais oui
c'est sur cette
affaire on a l'impression qu'ils vont
chercher les records serre co2 de lui
accorder l'essai de 7e melon d'or et
d'une certaine manière je pense qu'on
est toujours autour de cette table
d'accord pour dire que si messi devait
avoir un ballon d'or c'est si on
l'ensemble de sa carrière éventuellement
si sarah zone aussi sa récompense une
carrière entière en photo avec deux ou
trois très grands noms ils pourraient la
voir là on est sur une saison
effectivement je suis d'accord avec mike
sur une saison il ya eu il ya eu des
performances bien plus régulière bien
plus clinquante et bien plus marquante
c'est justement dans le dans le dans le
jeu du bayern par exemple que celle que
c'est lui messi après il ya sûrement le
contexte qui fait qu' il a il a trusté
quelques quelques votes et plus de votes
que les homos ce qui d'ailleurs on a
presque l'impression qu'il le savait
déjà on arrive en
strass et paillettes avec les enfants
moi je ne savais pas qu'ils ne savent ça
donne l impression d église on peut tous
ses ballons
pour le ramener à paris aussi patrice
evra avant même l'annoncé enfin avant
qu'ils aient annoncé le ballon d'or il
avait déjà annoncé sur les réseaux
sociaux
une semaine avant le ballon toujours
toujours ne boudons pas notre plaisir
effectivement ça arrive au psg mais
aussi le psg n'est pas responsable de
grand chose sur ce ballon d'or et
pour le coup pour le sema ine dans les
yvelines et danilo et si
j'avais à faire si jamais ça peut
déclencher quelque chose c'est que si si
il nous refait des prestataires hier
soir en ligue des champions contre
bruges là pour le coup ça voudrait dire
ok je me suis j'arrive avec mon aura de
barcelone je me suis adapté j'ai pris du
temps mais je me suis adapté au climat
notamment parce qu apparemment ça ça
joue beaucoup au climat parisien est
maintenant et maintenant je déroule et
ce qui est bien c'est que on en aura
besoin pour les huitièmes de finale dès
le printemps il fait par un mba pc un
bafé qui suit le match
mais le concert il hurle le contexte le
contexte est un but fabuleux le contexte
sportif c'est le meilleur match que je
l'aï vu faire depuis qu'il est au psg
moi mais je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec eux c'était pour messi pour le
ballon d'or pourquoi alors pas d'abord
alors greg et réseau c'est-à-dire qu'on
sait pas très bien c'est compliqué cette
ce ballon d'or qui est une distinction
individuelle dans un sport collectif
c'est vrai qu'il ya un truc qui va pas
dedans mais après les vendeurs ski très
bien mais c'était il devait l'avoir 2020
malheureusement il n'a pas eu en 2020 en
2021 avec le bayern et sont éliminés
pour une victime du film mal par un le
pays
la pologne mais robert green deal est
espérée le sauver si sur bèze avoir
besoin de baisser
la pologne
oui eliminé dès le
national avec la pologne 1 c'est
difficile de gagner un titre
bien sûr que c'est important les voix de
son américain la côte américaine était
choisie damien d'accord ça a pas été
d'un grand niveau faut dire la vérité
quand on a des nations comme le paraguay
la bolivie tout ça c'est comme se dire
la vérité large le brésil d'accord mais
dire que dire pour dire que grâce à ça
il a pu gagner le ballon d'or c'est un
hold up non après nancy 12e et c'est là
où c'est là où lionel messi son nom
parle de lui-même et son aura médiatique
c'est tout c'est que ça se joue que sur
ça il n'y a pas de débat pour les
déchets ce que disait pierre a été assez
parlé patrie personne ne s'impose est en
réalité la voie d'eau ce qui n'a pas
fait une sublime anne et 2028 a fait une
très très belle a dès 2020 si j'ai vu le
ballon d'or 2020 il l'avait tout le
monde était sûr qu'il l'avait en 2021
c'était beaucoup plus
critiquable fois c'était beau et donc
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce cas là
quand personne ne s'impose eh bien vous
a posé ses gains peu comme ces casiers
voilà où comme modiano à oman modiano on
l'avait oublié pour le goncourt et puis
un jour la donnée de coco pour eux ce
sont je le dis qu'ils ne représentent
pas le meilleur que quelques de ce qu'il
a écrit bas mais si c'est un peu pareil
c'est faute de mieux bon le donne au
meilleur joueur du monde messi est en
plus alors après moi c'est en tant que
supporter du psg eh ben je prêt que ce
soit un joueur du psg que du bailleur de
munich qui le porte et je vous emmerde
ce carton jaune carton
des statistiques j'ai rappelé les bons
dossiers aussi souffert mike commencent
à avancer cette idée doha médiatique à
une image il a souffert d'une image
peut-être trop lisse trop trop froide le
buteur un peu clinique devant le but qui
a pas trop d'émotions et si on regarde
pour servir vote c'est toute l'amérique
vote mais si l'asie et l'europe avant de
ski et l'afrique je crois aussi sûrement
mais quasiment le monde entier en fait
votre messi peut être parce qu'il est
plus connue celle aussi peut-être parce
que sans les destituer
jairzinho rarement j'ai une question
allez vous aussi créé mois d'émeutes à
paris voilà quand il se balade sans ce
sujet là on a le même des beau basket
ball quand un américain c'est pas pareil
c'est pas pareil quand un américain
n'est pas considérée par est donc compté
un brésilien dans le football quand un
argentin s'est pas non plus la même
chose après je reviens encore sur ce
sujet là on se pose la question on se
dit est ce que vraiment lunel messi
mérite d'être ballon d'or franchement
c'est abusé
de là à dire qu'il aurait fallu que le
rock il le fait à quelqu'un d'autre et
puis alors il est qui pour faire ça il
ya ya ya ya 200 journalistes pendant
mondiaux qui ont voté c'est pas le mec
qui va dire abordons donc finalement
j'ai à briller les couleurs derrière il
ya beaucoup de choses si la machinerie
individuellement cette balle andoche pas
sûr qu'on reverra ça dans l'histoire du
foot
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr que
rapidement le sheikh et après ça je suis
surtout pour cette élection il est le
choix dans la tête au niveau niveau fin
de saison parce que c'est c'est un
moment particulier notamment pour messi
parce qu'il a pas il n'a pas en voir une
à pleine mesure de son talent au psg va
pas dessus
juste 2 2 de l'ensemble de son oeuvre et
c'est je pense pour justement assez
honorifique et finalement finalement de
pouvoir
nous immuniser sur une valeur sûre c'est
pas cette fois justifié mais
la création de trophées de meilleur
buteur mieux c'est pas une compensation
parce qu'ils ont ils sauvé c'est parce
que ça jamais existé ce trophée mais
comme par hasard comme par hasard en
2013 assorti ce trophée là c'est quand
même sa choriste ce trophée avec
l'argentine s'était moins d'un an après
la disparition de d'armes de guingois
remonte de maradona est donc lui aussi
j'ai perçu symboliquement par symbolique
vraiment alors on va maintenant par les
olympiques de 2024 peut-être un sujet
peut-être moi moins passionnant aux
passionnés je ne sais pas mais voilà qui
se dérouleront comme vous le savez à
paris selon plusieurs sources le tracé
de l'épreuve ouverte pour la première
fois au grand public pourrait passer par
l'ancienne demeure du roi soleil à
versailles le 11 août 2024 si le départ
sera donné pont d'iéna à paris le reste
du parcours pourrait effectuer une
grande boucle dans les hauts de seine et
les yvelines selon à ces sources le
tracé pourrait emprunter le tracé du
paris à versailles ce mythique 16 km
entre paris et versailles donc un
parcours qui passe notamment par la
terrible côte des gardes à meudon 1 km
avec une cote à 7% et qui se termine
devant le château de versailles la
question sur ce thème est ce que c'est
une bonne idée de la part des
organisateurs d'utiliser le parcours du
paris versailles
oui ou non non pour vous
situer entre grégory à et pierre havre
et graille et vous commencez déjà de
dire que ce marathon pour tous qui
s'annonce pour 2024 je suis très curieux
de le voir qui sera voulez participer
j'ai pas le niveau n'est pas nouveau
mais en tout cas il est ouvert aux
amateurs sasebo ya mille coureurs qui se
sont qualifiés en battant eliud kipchoge
est la légende du marathon légende
kenyane donc déjà moi je suis
intéressés et curieux de voir ce tracé
maintenant pourquoi je dis que c'est une
bonne décision en tout cas faudra
attendre que ce soit confirmée et
officialisé c'est que on va s'appuyer
sur un parcours existence et on va pas
imaginer un nouveau parcours moi je
pense que c'est intéressant aussi de
s'appuyer sur des parcours qui existent
le paris versailles pas forcément c'est
un classique qui existe depuis quand
c'est merci merci pour mon petit mémo
1976 et il ya il ya des passages
classique vous les avez rappelé la
mythique côte des gardes qui arrive
après bien sûr sur ce château de
versailles qui a une cote très très
difficile donc moi je pense que c'est
intéressant de s'appuyer sur des choses
qui existent déjà qui fonctionne bien
pour construire un parcours d'un tracé
du marathon qui pourrait être un avis
intéressant pour 2024
moi je
j'utilise justement cette cet argument
pourrait bon nom en disant qu'il me
semble que pour un tracé de marathon
olympique de surcroît il y à une
question topographie et donc de dénivelé
qui ne soit pas trop positifs pour avoir
couru le paris versailles et s'ils
prennent la totalité des 16 km la
totalité du tout le parcours
effectivement cette côte des gardes l es
l et brice pathé et vous l'avez fait le
pari versa je vais voir et je peux dire
que la cote des gars qui arrive assez
tôt assez tôt dans le parcours est un
juge de paix immédiats mais il faut pas
oublier aussi que le reste du tracé il
ya une montée qui est pas mal non plus à
viroflay et n'oublions pas la venue de
paris qui est un qui est un espèce de
faux plat d'un kilomètre qui est qui et
qui est à trans et qui est qui qui rend
gros hf bien donc c'est juste pour dire
que s'ils en ont le droit évidemment
dans le droite sur une sur la partie
dénivelé et topographie s'éteint c'est
un terreau est magnifique mais je pense
qu'il y aura des contraintes justement
d'euros de planimétrie globale sur les
42 km après ça serait sûrement la fin du
parcours de ce marathon concrètement le
paris bercy les 16 kilomètres ça va
aller imaginez
alors patrice qu'est ce que vous en
pensez chien qui vous a contraint le
château de versailles quelques pages
suis toujours content
comme je ferai pas rivaux de sa main
tigana
non mais c'est vrai d'un an après est
comme ça fait 16 km et après on le fait
dans l'autre sens donc ça descend ça
serait ça serait à mon avis ils vont là
et pour l'allonger
d'accord ça va passer par paris quand
quelqu'un le bois de boulogne
à combler ça n'est pas assuré de paris
ça reviendra pas rien ça fera une boucle
s'est pas encore défini à 100% non je
trouve que c'est beau enfin c'est dans
l'image que ça venait dans le monde
entier quoi c'est vrai que par exemple
un excellent signal formidable et et je
veux dire pour les téléspectateurs du
monde entier six sites et ça aux jeux
olympiques ça serait ça serait très beau
maintenant peut-être que techniquement
en effet ce n'est pas le meilleur le
meilleur parcours mais j'ai totalement
incompétents d'ailleurs si c'était
confirmé ça ça confirmera que versailles
aura une place presque centrale dans ces
jeux olympiques jusqu'à l'est si vous
parlez dans le monde entier paris
versailles il y aura les épreuves de
d'équitation patate le moderne ya
peut-être aussi là le tracé cycliste qui
pas qui passera par versailles donc ça
sera une place de choix pour versailles
et donc ça on peut aussi savoir parce
que ce n'est pas trop pour versailles
peut-être mike sais pas trop il reflète
pas durant les uns pour les autres non
je pense pas je pense pas pour la simple
raison que
du coup voire quatre épreuves à
versailles finalement
oui oui oui mais après
maintenant si on a la capacité de faire
en
on le fait donc donc voila mais encore
une fois il faut souligner le travail
des grandes distances c'est ça qui est
important et puis aussi qu'on aime les
gens qui a s'est assez bien et est un as
et diversité par rapport à ça on a assez
de place pour le faire donc moi je crois
pourquoi on doit faire la fine bouche
ont confirmé hier
évidemment je confirme qu'il ya une une
telle ou telle aura une telle une telle
image de versailles à l'international
pour la culture d'abord pour l'histoire
mais si on peut en plus montré à quel
point versailles est une ville sportive
est une ville
esthétique esthétique et moderne ne nous
en privons pas là pour le coup là on
peut verser dans l'euphorie et et de
pouvoir et de pouvoir justement
accueillir le plus d'épreuves possible
si ça s'y prête et pour le coup c'est à
la fois télévisuelle et bien pour tous
les spectateurs évidemment bien pour la
ville de versailles
ouais
les épreuves ont pas été encore précisée
mais il restera des moyens de se
qualifier pour ce marathon pour tous moi
j'y participe à lula nous voilà c'est
officiel chez cette information comme ça
non mais il y aura d'autres
alors va maintenant prendre la direction
du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le président
de la fédération française pascal grizot
et brigitte henriques président du cnosf
ont présenté fin novembre une nouvelle
version de mon carnet de golf le livre
pédagogique multidisciplinaire qui avait
rencontré un grand succès auprès des
scolaires dans le cadre de l'accueil de
la ryder cup en 2018 à saint quentin en
yvelines souvenez vous cette interview
avait été réalisés en 2018 dans cette
école de voisins-le-bretonneux chien on
a deux thèmes généraux départ découvert
le golf et découvrir la ryder cup donc
je découvre je progresse
j'approche et je retiens
lorsque les enfants ont parcouru donc
ces pages ils ont déjà une culture assez
étendue par rapport au thème c'est c'est
vraiment bénéfique
cette fois ci le carnet sera centré sur
les valeurs de l'olympisme et les jeux
olympiques de 2024 pour illustrer les
épreuves de golf qui seront organisées
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le livre et
devrait être diffusé à plus de 3000
classe sur tout le territoire pour 90
mille élèves de cm1 cm2 et 6e la
question sur cette thématique ce carnet
permet-il de gagner de futurs licenciés
oui ou non
vous avait dégainé premier tiers
alors non pour vous falloir faire le
fier allez-y c'est une c'est une
réédition et c'est un moyen de rentrer
dans les écoles est de développer le
golf par sensibilisation on démarre par
casser les mythes et de justement de
montrer le golf par ses vertus part
c'est parce son enthousiasme il est il à
l avantage de la pratique et ont
justement on désacralise un petit peu
cette image cette image des golfeurs
poussiéreux en veste en tweed avec des
knickers et on rentre dans toutes les
écoles de france parce qu'il ya pagayer
pas que que dans le département mais
c'est justement une opération nationale
les élèves ont vulgarisé un petit peu et
surtout en fait on donne l'idée à des
enfants de d'aller sur un practice de
golf d'aller plus tard sur un parcours
de golf d'emmener leurs parents les
familles et donc on est dans une dans
une opération j'ai utilisé des gros mots
de vulgarisation ou de popularisation
qui est extrêmement bénéfique pour
l'ensemble après c'est ça créera des
licenciés pour l'instant l'opération
2018 on était sur des taux de
transformation assez faible sur une
classe de par exemple de 25 30 30
enfants il y en a peut-être deux ou
trois maximum donc un tout petit 10% qui
qui poursuivait en école de golf mais
c'est déjà ça et est là fédération
française de golf actuellement ne s'est
jamais aussi bien portée poste
confinement en termes de nombre de
licenciés que cette année et et ses
opérations là est justement pour emmener
les enfants spectateurs au golf national
qui est un stadium de golf on l'a déjà
dit absolument phénoménale c'est une
c'est une très belle option pour les
golfeurs et golfeuses de demain 400 2000
licenciés golf en france licencié je
précise à un parc pélican recalé sur les
mentalités ne sont trente mille en fin
d'année et ça sera plutôt bon c'est dans
ces eaux là alors moi je pense pas que
ça va forcément amener de nouveaux
licenciés vers le golf je pense que
c'est dans la veine en tout cas de
préparer ces jeux olympiques on dit
souvent sur ce plateau préparer l'ag la
génération 2024 il ya un événement
exceptionnel que peut-être ses enfants
connaîtront une seule fois dans leur vie
les derniers jo à paris ce temps 1924
donc voilà on va peut-être connaître
pour la seule fois de notre vie cet
événement donc c'est plutôt pour
conclure cette génération pas forcément
pour les amener vers le golf moi je vois
plus ça comme une stratégie un peu plus
globale comme ça peut être aussi
enclenché dans d'autres sports et je
pense que le golf on le disait non n'a
pas forcément besoin il ya une belle
progression dernièrement quatre cent
trente mille licenciés c'est ce qui est
annoncé pour la fin d'année le golfe qui
sait aussi
démocratisé grâce à des événements
internationaux la ryder cup va y avoir
les jeux olympiques et je pense aussi
que l a gagné aussi en publicité cette
discipline du golfe pendant le
confinement ou finalement va le golf un
moment donné c'était l'un des seuls
sports qu'on avait le droit de pratiquer
donc je pense qu'elle n'a pas forcément
besoin en tout cas ça peut être une
belle action pour vulgariser un peu plus
le golf mais moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus une stratégie globale pour
amener des enfants vers ces jeux
olympiques pas forcément partie
essentielle pour vous c'est un petit
plus soit absolument patrice qui vous a
convaincu vous êtes à
son service que rien
alosi et il ya quand même encore même
signé une progression du nombre de
licenciés il ya quand même une image du
golfe qui qu'il faut changer quand vous
avez eu la ryder cup regardez monde
avait annoncé la venue du prix du
premier ministre président de république
sont pas venus pourquoi probablement
pour une question d'image pour pas avoir
eu niveau accolé à un sport qui est
considéré encore comme un sport de 2,2
riches ou de privilégier donc ça c'est
très important et puis et puis les
exercices doivent être assez marrant
dans les carnets de golf juste dit qu'on
pourrait peut-être aller plus loin
puisque moi je me souviens avoir joué
une fois en belgique il y avait au
départ cette phrase et ça aurait pu être
un devoir de philo de quatre heures
n'oubliez pas que vous ne suivez pas
l'équipe qui vous précède mais que vous
procédez l'équipe qui vous suit
mike qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
non moi je suis d'accord acteurs aussi
parce que ce que j'aime bien en fait
dans cette démarche là c'est la
pédagogie en fait à travers l'école et à
travers un roman comme les essaie
d'instrumentaliser les choses je trouve
c'est une bonne pédagogie et puis les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'ils
vont construire l'avenir de demain donc
après ce qui est important dans sas et
ses travées dans la longévité c'est
continuer ce travail de fond et je pense
que ça va être ça va être une bonne
chose nous les basketteurs en herbe de
golf donc voilà
un
deuxième
essai d'autres dans le débat c'est ne
pas utiliser le terme de démocratisation
pas ce que ça veut dire qu'en gros on
cautionne l'élite l'élite et que ça
cesse a été
longtemps réservé à des privilégiés mais
il y avait déjà une offre qui était qui
était varié et qui étaient diverses il
ya tout type de parcours qui sont
ouverts certains qui sont privées qui
sont effectivement fermé mais la plupart
maintenant sondés sont notamment avec
les cent petites structures qui ont qui
ont fleuri avec la candidature de de la
france pour la ryder cup qui ont fleuri
un peu partout sur le territoire
français et qui maintenant sont dxo
voilà complètement dans des practice et
des 6 9 trous et qui sont des
formidables formidable lieu de rencontre
de partage autour du golf qui est qui
est un sport qui est un sport pour tous
finalement le sport d'une vie tous les
âges on peut jouer en famille en couple
entre amis et c'est très bien que qu'un
petit
dans tout l'est tout les sens il
attendait tous les niveaux avec incarne
ici leur donner envie ne serait-ce que
d'essayer ces salles en gros on risque
rien d'essayer
adapte aussi ce carnet et que leur
enseignement par exemple peut pas moi
quand j'étais allé dans cette classe
justement il avait proposé un dessin
animé autour de disney autour du golf
par exemple il était très intéressé à la
personne ne parlait dans la classe en
toc et on peut venir à paris des clubs
en plastique des balles en plastique sur
un tapis d'un tapis de practice dans la
cour de l'école ça c'est aussi un
avantage énorme sur la promotion du golf
est souvent sur un parcours de par 72
combien on fait trop ferez vous
et souvent ils sont allés à 50 ans ni
mais en tout cas ils sont allés sur
l'albatros à saint quentin aubague
national de saint quentin en limite pour
découvrir de leurs propres yeux ce qui
était un terrain de golf parce que c'est
pas forcément le cas pour tout le monde
donc plutôt positif
ça sera ça sera le mot de la fin sur
cette émission alors si vous voulez
télécharger mon carnet de golf vous
allez sur génération 2024 il est
disponible sur la plateforme du coup
génération de 1024 vous tapez ça sur
internet c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui en
référence à magic mike mongongu en
termine par une citation de l'ancien
basketteur michael jordan
si vous rentrez dans un mur n'abandonnez
pas trouvé un moyen de l'escaladé le
traverser ou travailler autour je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]